j'ai présenté mon ex belle femme il y a
ma maman
à Monaco
ma mère sur le chemin comment te dire
les mamans marocaines ont une
spécificité c'est que même quand elles
ont le trac elle doute elles sont
fébrile elles surjouit le fait qu'elles
sont à l'aise et ça donne des trucs
bizarres tu vois ce que je veux dire sur
le chemin du palais dans cette bagnole
je disais maman ça va c'est bon tu es
détendu mais pourquoi on va
quand même maman on va dans le palais on
connaît pas nous les rois et les reines
ben non maman on connaît pas moi j'étais
un peu en stress mais j'étais content
j'étais fier j'ai amené ma maman dans un
palais je vivais quelque chose de fou je
me rappelais de tout je venais c'était
fou et là j'avance et il le voit et
c'est un homme assez élégant assez
prévenant il me sert la main il me dit
je suis content de vous rencontrer
bienvenue détendez-vous on va faire ça
très cool on va manger un morceau avec
des amis on va faire ça à la bonne
franquette
et moi dans ma tête je me dis
[Musique]
sors le truc et claque nous fais nous
j'avais envie de lui dire on vient de la
franquette frérot on a passé notre vie
dans la frontière
[Applaudissements]